hi everyone sal here from khan academy
welcome to the homeroom live stream we
had a little bit of a hiatus but now we
are back i had a torn calf and other
things but i'm i'm i'm almost fully
recuperated uh but thanks for joining we
have a really exciting conversation
today with katie knight head of the
siegel family endowment but before we
start that i'll give some of my standard
announcements first a reminder that khan
academy is a not-for-profit organization
that we can only exist through
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about making a
donation to at khan academy.org donate i
also want to give a special shout out to
several organizations that uh stepped up
when they realized that not only was the
world leaning on khan academy as we had
mass school closures but khan academy's
cost had gone up and we were already
running at a deficit even before that so
special thanks to bank of america
google.org att fastly and novartis for
helping us fill some of that gap but we
still need more help so if you're in a
position to do so please think about uh
seeing if you can help out in some way
and then last but not least i want to
remind folks about homeroom with sal the
podcast
which is
essentially a version of what you're
seeing right now where we're taking kind
of the best of uh our live stream and
putting it in a format that you can
experience in your car without running
into other cars
so check that out wherever you get your
podcast so with that i'm excited to
introduce katie katie knight head of
executive director of the siegel family
endowment good to see you katie
it's good to see you too thanks for
having me
so maybe a good place to start is
what is a family endowment and what is
the segal family endowment in particular
what's its focus what does it do what's
the work of it
yeah that's a really good question so
endowment for us for some people this is
not true but for us is really just a
fancy uh replacement word for foundation
because someone else had already
established a single family foundation
and so david
a chairman and my boss
chose endowment and really we're a
foundation of private foundation so that
means we give away money but also engage
in other activities you know we support
research we support really great
nonprofits like khan academy uh that are
doing really important work out in the
world but um what we really try to do
that's a little bit different because
we're smaller foundation and a little
bit newer on the scene is also try to
think about how we can change
conversations how we can do some you
know thought leadership uh and really
are focused on on reframing questions
and ideas so not just writing a check
and sort of sitting back and hoping for
the best but really thinking about how
we can help change the conversation and
help people think about the impact of
technology on society which is our focus
in a different way and so you know that
is both the positive impact and the
sometimes negative impact of tech on
society and we're looking at both sides
of of the coin and trying to figure out
ways to leverage tech for good and also
to help mitigate some of the the
downsides that have come
yeah and as as you mentioned the siegel
family endowment is a long time major
funder of khan academy so everyone
watching who enjoys khan academy's
existence uh
plea please thank katie and david uh
who's family endowment uh this is and
i'm not saying that it's gonna be in the
room i would say this even if you
weren't in the i guess in the video
conference or whatever you're doing um
but but maybe a good a good place to is
to kind of double click on what you just
said that you know your focus is on tech
and it's
you know mitigating its negative
implications and promoting its positive
what are some of those things what are
some of the things that you all are
worried about that you know you have to
kind of actively make sure that tech
doesn't go
go bad so to speak and then what are the
things that you could promote where the
tech could be a force for good
yeah so i think we've seen a lot you
know in terms of um
misinformation or disinformation on the
internet where
tech and social media platforms
communication platforms can be used for
for bad where you have micro targeting
where you can really do things sort of
in the darkness um the sort of
underbelly of of tech and the way that
advertising and sort of conversation
targeting can work is really um
something that that we've been looking
at for a long time and lots of people
are looking at this from different
angles from academic researchers to
institutions that are trying to combat
and come up with practical solutions for
this stuff
so that's just one example i think you
know there are other
economic examples of how tech can um
canon has accelerated some of the divide
in the country when you think about
people who are benefiting the most from
from tech companies and those who aren't
so we look at at all of those things um
holistically and think about how they
intersect and how we can try to help uh
soften the the steep kind of
differences and how we can help
change some of that for the better i
think the flip side of that where you
can leverage tech for good is moments
like this where we're able to have these
sort of conversations share with people
new ideas new concepts online speak to
really broad audiences around the world
connect and share
where you have things like con where
people can learn outside of the
traditional classroom setting and really
have access to educational resources
that are really powerful and even the
same communication platforms i was
talking about before that have been used
for harm have also done a lot of good
for people who you know have found
community online where maybe they didn't
have it in person
yeah and i want to dig more into that i
know you've just published this white
paper on how infrastructure influences
everything but you know on that first
part around tech you know i am
fascinated and i know i don't think
anyone has like some obvious good
solutions here but you know you
mentioned kind of the micro targeting
and social media and you know the the
the conversations that i've been a part
of you know their social media and its
impact on especially young people and
their self-perception and could drive
anxiety and depression but there's also
social media for kind of polarizing us
where you only get
what you and maybe you engage even
deeper in something that polarizes you
even further
do you all have any i mean are y'all
talking some people that you think have
good solutions who can thread that
needle between
kind of free speech but not speech that
kind of does
it it's a it's a really difficult
question
yeah it is a really difficult question
and i think you know we have friends and
colleagues
at research institutions like the
stanford has a project um in their
philanthropy and civil society center
that's about sort of digital civil
society and the some of the researchers
who are associated with that are looking
at these questions i think
i think there are no easy answers one of
the things that i default to often that
i think is really important to talk
about is transparency so
i think human beings we're we're smarter
than maybe the tech and uh social media
platforms want to give us credit for and
if you
know that you're being shown search
results for example that are aligned
with one point of view that
an algorithm thinks is your point of
view or if you know that you're being
targeted by a specific sort of
advertising i mean that knowledge can be
really powerful in terms of helping you
understand the context around the
information that you're seeing and
helping you
think differently about whether or not
it's sort of true and verifiable we have
a really really wide range of resources
on the internet and some of them are
more fact-checked than others so i think
that transparency and context can do a
lot to help combat some of that sort of
polarization misinformation space and i
think that's one of the places where
practical solutions are being
experimented with um really
interestingly
no i really like to actually i haven't
heard that before but you're right if at
all you told me is like hey because you
are a middle-aged man who's into alien
conspiracy theories we are now going to
give you this
i think that is my profile
middle asian man who who likes to read
about alien conspiracy theories um
therefore here's your top search results
and i'm like wait i'm not a middle-aged
man and no i am um
i just turned 44 on sunday so
i have to i've come to terms with my
happy birthday i still can't get over
the fact that 44 plus 16 is 60.
i know i'm known for teaching math but i
i keep thinking i i'm doing the math
wrong but anyway back to the subject so
so on on on this notion of
infrastructure obviously which technical
infrastructure or digital infrastructure
is a piece and this is what you analyze
in your white paper
but i guess for maybe the first question
is why did you all decide to write a
white paper on
infrastructure
and what were kind of the big ahas
yeah so
a few things i will say that it started
because i am an infrastructure nerd
david is an infrastructure nerd we just
have always connected on questions and
thoughts about infrastructure i've never
met anyone who's called themselves an
infrastructure nerd so you get points
just for that and you know someone else
who's an infrastructure i'm probably an
infrastructure nerd too now that i know
that it's a thing yeah now that you know
it's a thing you are definitely a retro
nerd it's impossible not to be i think
once you actually dig into it um growing
up in new york city you know you take
the subways and you when you started to
ask questions well why is this train
late or what's happening over here and
what's going on with these tracks like
it gets fascinating really really
quickly and that's just the physical
infrastructure piece and so at first we
just started talking about how a
foundation like ours could be a part of
the conversation about infrastructure
and as we were digging in more and more
on the topic we had this work on on
digital infrastructure happening almost
separately where we were thinking about
things like the open source community
open learning platforms which is kind of
where we put
our khan academy relationship and sort
of like open learning and um started to
see these intersections the really
obvious one is broadband access as sort
of a physical
infrastructure asset
and your ability to access something
like an open learning platform
and so we started to talk and think just
a little bigger and a little wider about
what infrastructure could mean and
that's what the first big aha was was
that infrastructure had to be
more than just about the the bridges the
roads that really this triangle of
physical digital and social
infrastructure
that's how we need to be thinking about
the assets that we should be investing
in the things that we should care about
the things that the government should be
you know safeguarding
our physical digital and social assets
that are sort of underlying all of a
society
and keeping us functional
this is fascinating and i want to remind
everyone watching feel free to put
questions on youtube and facebook and we
and our team will surface it to myself
and katie and ask really about anything
about infrastructure about endowments
about you know i'm going to ask katie a
little bit about how she even found
herself in this role so uh really ask
both me and katie anything you all want
but just double clicking on that katie
you know like i'm very i think most of
us are familiar with physical
infrastructure those are roads and
bridges and dams and power lines and
things like that and i think we can
imagine digital infrastructure which is
related to physical infrastructure which
is i mean i guess you could debate
whether it's physical or digital but
it's you know
having internet connectivity or at least
having a device or maybe no you know
having support for using that device
what is social infrastructure
yeah so social infrastructure is really
a little bit more intangible you're
thinking about sort of the networks that
you're a part of the relationships that
you have with other people the
one
idea that i've talked about with people
before is the notion that perhaps access
to child care for example is
infrastructure because if you're a
parent as as you are so you know that in
order to work you need someone to help
take care of your kids and so how people
are able to contribute to the economy
and be a part of that is really
important to sort of the nation's health
and prosperity so thinking about social
infrastructure as an element that
matters i think it is a little bit
trickier and can vary also depending on
the sort of community that you're in so
you know for some people having access
to space where you can um
sort of co-working space where
entrepreneurship and a culture of
entrepreneurship is
being being built can help them
launch new businesses and
contribute to their local economy we've
invested in some work in um in rural
america related to helping create
space and cultures of entrepreneurship
to kind of revive economies so really it
can vary um you can see
in this illustration that we talk about
the
digital economy we talk about libraries
libraries are a place where i think that
physical digital and social
infrastructure really intersect where
you get
both the
access to tech the physical space where
you have information knowledge and also
it's you know opportunities to take
classes to maybe learn a new language to
access information about how to get
online and how to use new technology all
of that can happen at a library which is
why they're one of our our big examples
in the paper and kind of a space for
really exciting new ideas i think about
what um what social infrastructure and
what infrastructure and communities can
look like
now that you've named social
infrastructure i now realize not only am
i an infrastructure nerd i think i'm a
social infrastructure nerd because i
spent a lot of time
thinking about how maybe how do we
social engineer i mean even in our
direct life
which obviously is more kind of a
personal thing like how do we make sure
we have deeper friendships how do we
make sure our kids have places they can
go to uh but then how do you architect
that on a larger scale super super
fascinating what are your big
you know big takeaways like what part of
infrastructure are we doing well as a
society are there examples of other
countries that are doing a better job
where where if y'all were you know
emperor of the universe uh where where
where would you invest how would you
invest that
i think um
on many fronts were not doing so well so
even on the physical infrastructure
front we've seen you know the american
society of civil engineers puts out a
report card on how our infrastructure is
doing they gave us a a d plus
which is not a great grade
and
that's before you consider these sort of
additional dimensions we have that being
said you know in there are bright spots
there are towns and cities with access
to fiber um
you know high-speed internet there are
places where the library systems are
doing an incredible job with reinforcing
this the social infrastructure and sort
of coming into the the new century with
these opportunities for people to get
online and to learn how to do things
that will help them get jobs and be a
part of this new innovation economy um
i think overall we should be thinking
differently about how we spend the
dollars that we have to build new things
and to sort of
fix the old things we haven't done a
great job of of maintenance ongoing
maintenance but we should be investing
with an eye toward how any dollar that
we spend should have a payoff on all
three fronts not just one and so i'm not
going to say that we shouldn't spend
more money i think we do need to spend
more money it happens at the state and
local and federal levels but that we
could also spend you know the same
amount of money and probably do a better
job of it if we looked at things and
thought about the payoff and and also
brought people to the table who
represented all three sides of the
triangle
yeah to your point sometimes the same
effort can actually hit all three sides
if it's thought out what's your sense of
why we have under i mean even just on
physical infrastructure it feels like
that's even like it's not not it
shouldn't be a political issue i you
know i i don't think anyone argues with
better roads safe bridges
you know good uh utility infrastructure
et cetera et cetera and because you
suffer it's very apparent when it's bad
it's very apparent when bad things
happen or when you know
power lines go down things like that why
haven't hasn't there why do we have this
degrade right now
i think it's a few things you know our
infrastructure in the us especially is
super decentralized so
more spending more funding for
infrastructure comes from the state and
local level than the federal government
even though people think about i think
you know the federal government when you
think about something as big as
infrastructure but actually even in the
physical sense you know most highways
are actually owned at the state level
not at the federal level even though
lots of federal investment went into
creating the highway system and
interstates and that sort of thing um
we
are not necessarily
thinking about you know
the future when we
make infrastructure investments either
so
we are looking to fix kind of the
immediate problems right in front of us
but not thinking about the future uses
and future needs so by the time you can
get an infrastructure project through
the bureaucracy it can often already be
outdated before you know things even
start being built and i think anything
that involves spending unfortunately
becomes a political issue of course and
again if you if we could think
differently about how to spend um
smartly we might all i think everyone
loves a deal maybe deals and bargains
are not necessarily political so if we
can make the case that like you're
getting a really good deal by investing
in infrastructure and looking at it
through these three lenses then perhaps
we could get people to spend more money
or invest differently without it
becoming a political issue
yeah the argument with any investment
including infrastructure is it should
have some return if you build a bridge
people have a shorter commute time it'll
increase commerce and that will generate
even you know not only more productivity
which will generate more tax revenue
which you can use to pay for more
infrastructure you know there's a
question here and it's related to one i
just asked you uh it's from youtube
hasset gases
why is america's infrastructure why do
we think america's infrastructure is
worse than say germany's infrastructure
first of all do you have a sense that
that is something like that true and you
know it feels like a very comparable
country is it based on how it's
structured and the the decentralized
natures it's something else it's just
we're different than germans and how we
how much we care about our roads and
bridges and things
yeah i think there are a lot of
potential answers to that question and
i'm sure that there are people who will
agree and disagree with my point of view
on it i think it's a combination of all
those things you know the us is is vast
um even though i think we have
comparables in other countries like lake
germany or or even places in asia like
like japan or china where they've done
it i think a good job building
infrastructure physical infrastructure
we also
do have this really different
decentralized system
and
we do have i think a different approach
in terms of how we think about whose
responsibility is to take care of these
things and how quickly we're able to to
move and to gain
the sort of
partnership and create the opportunity
for new things to be built i think we
haven't made it as much of a priority to
invest in our infrastructure in the us
as some other places have
and it's a related question
from facebook christabel mendoza asks
which cities in the u.s would be good
models that successfully encompass
physical social and digital
infrastructure
that's a really good question and i'm
i'm hoping that as part of what we're
doing with talking about this paper out
in the world that people will share more
examples with us of where they've seen
really great things happening whether
that's in a city state or even just a
town i think there are really good
examples at all levels and all sizes of
how infrastructure
these three pieces of infrastructure can
come together to work better together um
we have some good examples in the white
paper of places
um like like kansas city that have
really leveraged their their access to
fiber internet to create new
opportunities that's coming back to that
library's example we were talking about
some of the towns that we work with
through our rural work i'm not going to
name them because there are now over
a dozen and i don't want to
miss any but there are a few called out
also in the paper or if you sort of
scroll through the the website which i
think the link is somewhere on the on
the bottom of the screen um you can kind
of click through some of the the map
that we have which calls out a few a
handful of towns where we've invested
that are doing a good job
with this physical digital social um
framework
are most of the examples i mean you've
given one example of like you know a
fiber optic you know high bandwidth
that's both physical you know someone
has to dig up the
and put lay down that that fiber but
that's obviously digital infrastructure
as well and then you make it available
in schools and libraries and then the
community can benefit and they're having
kind of a social connection which is a
social infrastructure are there other
examples beyond and there's a question
here uh from susanna garcia dominguez hi
katie what is the best optimization you
have
idea you have heard about infrastructure
is it more of kind of this library
flavor of things with high-speed
broadband are there other kind of cool
ideas you all have been thinking about
i think well we'd love to hear cool
ideas from all over so there's a place
both on the website but also sort of our
emails are accessible so we're always
sort of happy to hear pie in the sky
ideas for optimization here i think a
lot of what stands out is related to
this you know internet access just
because especially right now especially
in the context of this pandemic we've
seen that be
so so important and and we've seen that
there's still such an incredible divide
in in the country in terms of who has
strong internet access and who doesn't
and i think that's why so many of the
examples that are top of mind for me
right now and that feel you know
innovative and important are related to
that but i think we're really open to
new ideas for how to optimize the using
the framework and want to experiment and
find places that are interested in sort
of
just taking a chance on this idea and
implementing some new things
and do you think you know i i've
been talking to a lot of folks lately
and i said you know this covet situation
with school closures is not good it's a
sub-optimal but if there's a silver
lining it's that there's more energy
than ever in trying to close the digital
divide are you all seeing that and you
know on a scale of one to ten how
hopeful are you that in the next five
years digital divide at home at least in
the us uh has is closed a good bit
i'm really hopeful about that i think we
have seen um not just energy and
enthusiasm around closing the digital
divide more than ever we've also seen i
think renewed interest from from the
private sector in helping us get there
which is one of the things that we talk
about in the paper a bit too is you know
we need to think beyond just the
government has money and should invest
here but thinking about how the private
sector how the social sector the
philanthropic sector nonprofit world
that i'm a part of everyone contributes
to infrastructure both in terms of the
capital the money that we're spending
but also just the thoughts and the
governance of infrastructure and how we
shape it moving forward so i think that
is something i'm super hopeful about in
terms of closing digital divide i think
we have a long way to go and we have to
keep pushing even if we get back to a
place where school is more in person
than it has been even if we're able to
work from offices again this still
matters right it's not just if you have
to do school on zoom that you should be
worried about the digital divide it
matters if you're trying to do homework
at the end of the day it matters for all
sorts of reasons so i think if we can
maintain this energy that we all have
around making sure that more people have
access i feel really hopeful that we can
solve this problem because we actually
know how to solve it like you bring the
access to the people like you said you
dig the holes and you lay the fiber
cable you do those things and we can get
access to folks who need it
yeah and there's other things i'm
hopeful of you know obviously the whole
starlink project elon musk's micro
satellites that he's gonna
put all that he's already putting into
orbit you know that'll give us internet
access almost almost anywhere uh yeah
but good to hear that you're similarly
hopeful because it does feel like you
know clean drinking water or just basic
shelter um in the decades to come maybe
in the the remaining time i do always
like to ask you we have sometimes a lot
of young people watching and i remember
when when i was a young person
i would always wonder you know how do
you know you know certain careers
doctors lawyers engineers and you can go
to certain schools and kind of
eventually
end up being one of those professions
but there's clearly many other jobs in
the world that have less clear career
tracks like being the executive director
of a family foundation
how did you did you see yourself doing
this what did you think you were going
to do and how did you how did you end up
in this role
yeah it's sort of a funny story and i'll
try to i'll try to tell you the abridged
version but you know when i was in in
high school and in college in my sort of
early years of college i thought that i
wanted to work in the nonprofit sector i
thought that i wanted to start a
non-profit and then i learned that
there's too many nonprofits and you
probably don't need to start a nonprofit
of your own but maybe you could go work
in one and then i learned about
philanthropy and i said oh well better
to sit on the other side of the table
sounds good to give away money for a
living
and um
i really quickly learned that there was
not a clear career path into
philanthropy that it's very um sort of
bespoke it depends a lot on the
different
foundations individually and that there
are not a ton of entry-level positions
so i sort of forgot about it i put it to
the side and i said maybe i'll get there
one day
you know until then i'll go back to my
idea of working in the non-profit sector
and
i did work in a non-profit in phil i
would just school in philadelphia and i
lived there for a few years after i
graduated i worked at a very cool
nonprofit there that um actually is a
giant puppet
part theater but also sort of social
activism
non-profit um called spiral q
and
i giant puppet park theater
it's so like when you're just a giant
puppet i was like what what more is it
but now i think i understand it it's a
giant problem
they um are invested in sort of social
activism and it started a long time ago
as just they would build these giant
puppets and their protest puppets and
and there's a sort of i can share a link
later with anyone who's actually curious
about this it's um but it was a great
time and then um there's a little bit of
luck i happened to um get a job at
google when they were launching google
plus because they thought there were
some interesting use cases for the
non-profit sector and i had that
experience
and then while i was at google i took
this sort of winding path through doing
many things with the organization one of
those things was corporate social
responsibility community engagement work
and that took me
down a
interesting journey of learning what it
was like to connect with the community
as sort of a representative of the
company
got me some experience with giving money
away for a living and that um then took
me to david's company and then
eventually
david and i just realized that you know
we had things in common and sort of
thought the same way and i started to
work with the
what was then very small team at sfe
and it just so happened that the timing
was right and i wound up kind of taking
a job working just directly with david
on the philanthropy and um just last
year actually became the executive
director after we had some some changes
so i think that's probably not a helpful
answer if you're trying to launch a
career in philanthropy i will say two
things one a little controversial not
going to graduate school actually turned
out to be really great for my career um
i may still go to graduate school one
day who knows with this online world i
may be able to swing it but um i always
really wanted to go to grad school but
could never decide what i would focus on
because i'm just
all over the place and think about
different things every hour
but not going to graduate school and
sort of not focusing made me a little
more adaptable and so i would pick up
any opportunity and look it as a chance
to learn something and try it on for
size and that kind of took me to a
really interesting place in my career
and the other thing is just you know
i was lucky and timing played a big role
and i think
timing and luck are what they are but
you have to again be open to like the
opportunity you have to be
trying to make the timing work so
consider anything that sort of comes
your way as a chance to do something
different and sort of see where it takes
you and you may end up running a
foundation
i'm surprised that you say you like
giving money away i think asking for
money is so much fun
being something no it's actually fun to
have not very good at that either i'm
not great at asking for money
no asking for money is not indeed yeah
you got to kind of ruffle up your hair
have your puppy dog eyes and
[Laughter]
people though everyone should give money
to khan academy
i agree with you i agree that's a really
good point i agree with you
um very high social return on investment
um
the
last question and it's related to what
the one we just we just talked about
from youtube bashar ashtar says what are
some challenges you think the next
generation will face and i'll just
broaden it you know you're someone that
is a young person you you're already
thinking i want to do something that has
some social impact do good for the world
i think a lot of young i think most
young people are in that same frame but
there's like how do i do you know what
do you think are the you know any
problem is an opportunity so what do you
think are some of the ones that they
should start thinking about
yeah i mean i know that so many young
and younger people are thinking about
this already but climate and climate
change
so so important for us to be thinking
about we
um older people should also be doing a
better job tackling climate change but i
think there's so much opportunity to
anything from inventing new technologies
to starting new nonprofits or social
movements related to that like that work
is so important and
we have to to solve these problems um
there's no choice but to solve them so i
think that's one that i would i would
call out but you know coming back to
some of the stuff we were talking about
earlier i think
thinking about how tech can be used for
good is not just a non-profit sector
issue it's an issue for anyone whether
you're an academic whether you're
doing private sector work no matter what
you can be looking at the world and
thinking
how can what i'm doing contribute to
solving problems rather than creating
more problems i think um
if we did more of that no matter what we
were doing we would all be better for it
no well that's that's great advice and i
can't imagine yeah it's a very
existential issue of climate change so
that's a good one to highlight but
there's there's many many more well
katie whenever we have these
conversations the time always goes by
faster than i expect
but thank you so much for joining this
this was a real treat and thank you for
your support over the years i'm not
joking it's been a big part of what
allows khan academy to be khan academy
well thank you thank you for all that
you do i still watch khan academy videos
when i need to learn something new or
refresh my memory so appreciate your
work um in more ways than one on a
personal level and what you're doing for
the world and this was fun it's always
fun to talk to you but also great to
talk to sort of everyone else out there
yeah last time we met i remember that
that right this is all pre-covered where
we could go to a restaurant
restaurant there was i remember there
was like some cheese fries that i was i
was having like
self-control issues with but
anyways you just needed sustenance it
happened to be yeah my whole life is all
about discipline and
like but then the the levy breaks and
anyway
whole other whole other conversation
thank katie
thanks
well thanks everyone for joining as
always a really fun conversation with
katie and i hope actually hopefully we
can get david siegel on as well from the
segal family endowment in the next
several weeks uh but thanks everyone for
joining our next uh homeroom
is gonna be tomorrow uh with arne duncan
uh secretary of education in the obama
administration and he's a managing
partner at chicago cred he does really
incredible work with young people
especially in chicago so um
uh arne duncan who i also consider to be
a a good friend and an all-around good
guy so i look forward to that
conversation tomorrow so thanks everyone
for joining and and i'll see you
tomorrow with with secretary duncan
you